remember the times when we were eagerly
waiting for our favorite TV shows to air
missing an episode was heartbreaking
and there wasn't any other way to watch
it again but now thanks to the
flexibility online media streaming
services provide you don't have to worry
about missing any of the episodes so
when show are you currently watching
right now I'm watching money heist on
Netflix and it's a really good show
speaking of Netflix have you guys ever
wondered how Netflix works well today we
are going to talk about the science
behind Netflix Netflix is considered to
be one of the biggest internet
television networks with 158 million
paying subscribers across the globe
starting off in 1997 but allowed people
to rent DVDs online in 2007 it came out
with its own streaming services
customers could watch shows and movies
on their computers TV screens phones or
gaming devices in 2013 it began
competing directly with TV networks and
cable for original content as of 2019
Netflix is the world's largest online TV
streaming service but how does it happen
what does Netflix do that is competitors
don't well the answer is machine
learning
AI and big data analytics Netflix uses a
content delivery network to store and
transmit movies and TV shows
first Netflix gives the content by
negotiating licensing deals with TV
shows and film makers depending on the
location popularity and purchasing
rights Netflix displays different
content for its users across the globe
that is why what you watch in the u.s.
is different from what you watch in
India but do you know there are also few
shows in movies which are common to all
the users irrespective of their
locations like Netflix originals house
of cards hit TV shows and new releases
Netflix has over 7,000 movies and shows
and it is nearly impossible for us to
find what we would like to watch so how
does Netflix recommend these shows
to do this job
Netflix uses its recommendation engine
imagine if you were new to Netflix in
the beginning you would have to take up
this survey and pick up the genres you
are interested in but after that Netflix
fine-tuned those recommendations to
provide you with a more personalized
experience which means my recommendation
list will be different from yours
machine learning is necessary for this
method because it uses user data to make
informed suggestions later such as water
your wash previously your ratings search
history and so on all this complex data
is analyzed and finally a conclusion is
drawn in addition to these personalized
engines waters catches your attention
well it is the thumbnails visually
appealing thumbnails grab our attention
and there's something that we click on
isn't it yes Netflix doesn't usually use
them shows original cover art it uses
algorithms to extract high quality
images from the respective videos with
the help of a static visual analysis and
creativity
Netflix comes up with a catchy
thumbnails so this was all about the
science behind Netflix I hope you guys
enjoyed this video do like and share it
also subscribe to our Channel and hit
the bell icon thank you for watching and
stay tuned for more from central on
[Music]